[Music]
this was very much a government rally
organized by the mayor's office in addis
ababa
but thousands of people turned up at
mexico square
carrying placards that expressed their
anger at tigris tplf leadership
and its forces that many here refer to
as
junta and support of prime minister abi
ahmed's government
and its federal army
for a long time tplf has brought
division on the people so we have to
begin to forget about them
forget about the past and be united
behind and be united behind our defense
force
this government has a lot of moral
support they need to take strong action
against the junta that steals
those who address the crowd had this to
say
a few international media witnessed the
juniors using children for war
they witnessed this but did not report
it and that shows their interests
it shows who they are above all the
intent is to support the juniors as they
see ethiopia bleed
federal troops have withdrawn from
tigrai but the soldiers
eritrean troops and special forces from
neighboring amhara region
have been accused by rights groups of
committing crimes against civilians
including killings and rape those who
came to this rally say they fully
support the government
in the ongoing tigray conflict but the
situation there is dire fighting
is still going on in some parts drawing
in security forces from
other regions that were not previously
involved
in the fighting and the un and other aid
agencies saying
that they're struggling to get to the
most vulnerable people
in that region there has been recent
fighting between federal troops
and regional forces from oromia against
the grand fighters in
areas bouldering tigray and afar region
a world food program aid convoy was
attacked on sunday
on the only remaining ground
humanitarian corridor into tigray
this is devastating to millions of
people who desperately need help
shortages of fuel and cash as well as
communications blackouts
are significantly hindering the
resumption of the humanitarian response
and preventing its scale up ngos and un
agencies are running out of cash and are
unable to pay staff or suppliers
unless fuel cash supplies and aid
workers are able to enter tigray in the
coming days
some humanitarian programs will not be
able to function
these are dangerous times in ethiopia
and all fighting sites are trying to
control the narrative
media access into tigra is limited
because of multiple national government
and regional special forces checkpoints
along the road
and an airspace on the open for
humanitarian flights
catherine soy al jazeera addis ababa